Welcome to our fifth week of
Shaping the Future of Work.
My name is Christine Riordan,
and I am a PhD student here
at the Institute for Work and
Employment Research at MIT.
I'm filling in for
Professor Kochan
this morning, who you will
hear from later in the week.
There are two items that
we want to highlight as we
start this week of the course.
One is our upcoming topic
regarding worker voice
and good quality
jobs in the context
of changing forms of work.
The second is something
we're really excited about,
which is a simulated negotiation
over the future social contract
at work, something that you will
be participating in next week,
and which really brings all
of the ideas and this course
together in a very concrete way.
So this week, we're
going to get you set up
for that negotiation.
But first, our focus on
worker voice and advocacy.
So last week, we heard from
a number of individuals
about new arrangements
and forms of work,
whether it be new
patterns of job growth,
the organization of
work through technology,
or new strategies
in entrepreneurship.
From the discussion
boards, these
seem to be topics that
resonate with your thinking
about the future of work, not
only in terms of your own jobs
or careers, but also in the
bigger picture of the labor
market.
Within this realm, the
issue of job quality
is front and center.
So these two things,
changing forms
of work and good
employment practices,
are critical to our upcoming
module on worker voice
and advocacy.
We're going to extend
this discussion
to consider how worker voice
and organizing are changing
as new forms of organizing
work are emerging.
To do so, we're going
to first discuss
the decline in union
membership, a traditional means
of exercising voice on the job.
We'll identify some of
the ways in which new work
arrangements are challenging
voice and job quality.
We'll then talk about how new
forms of worker organizing
are starting to adapt to
these changes and challenges.
Firms, as we'll see, are
also making decisions
on how they integrate new ways
of doing work, such as those
brought by technology, in
ways that maintain good job
standards.
However, we want
to take a moment
to emphasize an
important point that
puts these discussions
in a broader context.
In a number of our
videos and discussions,
we've talked about
alternative work arrangements
such as freelancing
or contracting,
and on-demand, or gig, jobs.
According to a recent study
by US economists Lawrence Katz
and Alan Krueger, such
alternative arrangements
have grown, most notably
in the last 10 years,
and now account for about
15% of workers' jobs
throughout the US.
This growth in the
visibility of arrangements
like those of the
on-demand economy
are bringing renewed attention
to related labor market
challenges.
Still, some of
these arrangements
make up a relatively
small portion of jobs.
The on-demand
economy, for instance,
accounted for less than
1% of total employment
in 2015, according
to Katz and Krueger.
So given this, there
are really two tasks
at hand in this week's agenda.
One, as we've stated, is to
understand emerging forms
of voice that overcome
some of the challenges
in these arrangements.
In our videos and
Additional Resource section,
you'll see inspiring
examples and accounts of how
change is being achieved.
The second task is
to critically examine
what these new
challenges are telling us
about the overall labor market.
Encouragingly, we have
arrived at a point where
we are engaging in public
discourse about issues
like the rights of
independent contractors
with on-demand companies
like Uber or TaskRabbit.
One way to think
about this discourse
is that it provides a
window, or a way in,
to thinking about the challenges
found throughout the labor
market and experienced by
workers across the board,
whether in an alternative
arrangement or not.
So given this, the
question we ask becomes,
how can we take the ideas
and the proposals and lessons
we learned from
these emerging forms
and use those to think
critically about solutions
to challenges and the need
for a stronger role of worker
voice across different
segments of the labor market,
like those discussed by Bureau
of Labor Statistics chief
economist Heidi
Shierholz last week?
Doing so places our
thinking in the trajectory
we've been on throughout
this course, which
has focused in recent weeks
on the gradual demise of labor
market institutions and the
social contract at work.
We're excited to see
how you're thinking
about these in the discussion
boards over the coming week.
Now, on to the
negotiation exercise.
In week six, you'll be engaging
with your course colleagues
in dialogue regarding different
actions and employment
practices that can
serve as building
blocks for the new
social contract at work.
To do this, you'll
be assigned to groups
and will negotiate from the
perspective of a given role,
including management, labor
unions and professional groups,
the federal government, or
educational institutions.
The idea behind this is to bring
all of our lessons and material
together in a
concrete way, but one
that hinges on your
creativity and participation.
So the outcome of
the exercise is
really dependent upon
having as many perspectives
and participants as possible.
This week, you're given basic
information and instructions
for the negotiation.
You're also asked to
sign up for the exercise
and fill out a short
preparation survey.
We encourage all of
you, whether you're
taking the class for
a certificate or not,
to participate so that we
can collectively really make
the most out of this
opportunity to think creatively
about the issues we care about.
Next week, you'll receive
your role and your group
assignments, and we'll
start your negotiations.
On our discussion board, you'll
notice a new thread entitled
"Negotiation Exercise"
where this week and next,
you can post questions or let
us know if you need assistance.
We hope that you'll join
us for the exercise,
and for a live event
presentation in week
seven, the details of
which we'll post soon.
There we'll talk about
your plans for action.
So stay tuned. s